each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning before I get on to what I
had actually planned for lecture 5 I
wanted to cover two things briefly from
lecturer for so first of all mr. Deepak
rajendra prasad asked very good question
couldn't the private multiplicative way
to algorithm have been run using noise
scale to square root K log 1 over Delta
over epsilon directly without having to
compose it with itself and without
noising the initial threshold and the
answer to his question is yes and in
fact that's how the algorithm was
originally written but the proof of
privacy is much more complicated than
the proof that I showed you yesterday
via competition so the point was to give
you a new and simpler proof but he was
right I also wanted to clarify the last
two slides because I ran out of time and
got a little flustered so I just want to
go over what was happening in the
boosting algorithm remember that in the
boosting algorithm we chose a small set
of K queries we call those samples and
we feed these to the base learner so the
key step is feeding k queries to the
base sanitizer to obtain an object that
does well that is answers within some
bound error bound of lambda on a one
half plus eight a fraction of the
distribution so to do this we actually
need to show three things the first is
really magic and that's why it's in a
different color it's a generalization
bound that shows for every em and i'll
give you the formal statement although
not the proof on the next slide if we
have an m-bit object
and bit so we're measuring it in bits an
n-bit long object that gives lambda
accurate answers for the database on a
randomly chosen set of K queries where K
is bigger than M so it's a small number
of bits compared to the number of
queries not measured in bits just number
of queries that it answers then with
high probability it gives you a good
answers on a significant you know
significantly more than half of day so
most of date you also need a higher
level explanation of how we build the
base learner including the number of
samples that we need and the role of the
Laplace noise in that process and then
for homework you can count so we'll have
some tea rounds we have K samples per
round the only place where we're losing
privacy is on these samples we get K
times T samples total each sample we saw
from the attenuated re waiting has
sensitivity 1 over mu and this will tell
us how we have to scale Sigma and then
we need to go back and check that we can
build a base learners that have such a
fat Sigma and still have enough accuracy
and that will tell us how large we can
hope the query set Q will be so it's
another one of these situations where
you have three or four interrelated
parameters and you just have to sort of
work on them and and and try to fit them
together so the lemma oh oh oh yeah so
let's start with the high-level
explanation of how we build the base
learner it's very very easy suppose we
have some number K of samples we're
gonna take some number K of samples
where K is going to be more or less
times in log of the universe size where
this is the universe of data elements so
this is this factor Kappa may be bigger
than one all right
now for every query in that sample set
we're going to use the Laplace mechanism
to get an approximate answer for the
value of the database on that query q of
x we add Laplace noise so that's our
approximation of response r of x which
has privacy now built in because of the
Laplace mechanism so this gives me a
bunch of answers to these queries
approximate answers to these queries and
now this is for arbitrary query sets not
counting queries we're going to
exhaustively search in a ridiculous
amount of time that's just too
embarrassing to discuss we're going to
exhaustively search through all n Road
databases remember that our original
database had size in so it certainly
gives good answers to these queries but
there will also be others that give
pretty good answers to these queries so
we're going to exhaustively search for a
database that's n rows that means it's
exactly M which is n Times log of the
universe size number of bits long ok and
that database which we find my exhibit
and this thing has to give relatively
accurate answers where accuracy now is
to this noisy thing not to the truth if
it's close to the noisy thing and
nothing weird happened in the Laplace
sampling it will be close to the truth
but we're ensuring privacy by using R of
X here rather than the true Q of X all
right so we're looking for an in row
thing that that does well has an Arab
most lambda over to on every query in
our sample set no notice that this is n
log n bits this is something bigger than
n log n queries so the presence of K
means that Y is shorter than the number
of queries that it's a
answering and that was the condition
that I described on the previous slide
okay the generalization bound looks like
this you don't really have to
internalize it too much and I'll just
show you a little intuition on the next
slide why it works here's kappa you can
verify later that this is in fact bigger
than one so what it says is if we have a
small string that answers enough queries
pretty well then it will in fact give
you something that answers most of d
with high probability high probability
over the choice of samples so here's the
key observation consider any in bit
string y which is a candidate synthetic
output no we're going to exhaustively
search so we have one candidate then the
next candidate than the next candidate
once we have fixed this string why there
is some set let's call it B sub y the
bad queries for y on this bad set the
value that we get on why is far from the
value on the database all right so every
string Y may have a non-empty bad set
now if the fraction of strings that are
bad for y from the universe of queries
as a whole is bigger than m / s what's
the probability when we randomly choose
s that Y will sort of be good for
everybody that we chose there's we have
this white why has a big fraction of bad
queries we're going to choose a random
set of queries what's the chance that we
miss all the bad ones if we miss all the
bad ones we might not rule out why if we
hit a bad one will definitely rule out
why so what's the chance that we miss
all of them and
don't roll why out well a little bit of
arithmetic shows that that's going to
look like e to the minus M now how many
bad wise are their homework with high
probability simultaneously for all Y
where be why is large s will intersect
to be why there by knocking y out so
this is what I should have told you
yesterday and that's good okay good so
the themes for the lecture is so far
were first lecture was definitional and
Laplace mechanism randomized response
the second lecture was selection and the
connection to economics the third
lecture was privacy as a random variable
the fourth lecture was sort of the heavy
learning kind of stuff and concise
representations and sparse vectors and
the fifth lecture is basically fun and
games so this is going to be an easy
lecture remember the subsample and
aggregate paradigm of a nice team Russ
coding Kevin Smith so the idea was you
have some function you don't necessarily
understand your function you want to
compute F of your database in a private
way you have no idea what the
sensitivity of your function is so you
can take your data partition it randomly
into blocks apply the function to each
block independently and then somehow
aggregate the results in a
privacy-preserving way that was the
paradigm what happens when your function
is Steve Feinberg Steve Feinberg is a
statistician ah he's very interested in
has done a lot of work on
confidentiality and he says I must see
raw data
cannot work through a privacy-preserving
interface that doesn't let me stare at
raw data now I trust Feinberg I trust
his intentions I trust that he'll be
honorable but even he could accidentally
study the data and release some
statistic that is somehow discloser even
though he didn't mean it to be so let's
conceptualize Feinberg as a function
right it's just some function i don't
know the sensitivity of this function i
don't understand this function i doesn't
I don't know what happens in the
statisticians brain when he sees raw
data he cannot explain this to me but I
trust him so let's call him a function
so suppose Feinberg is energetic and if
I take the data and I split it up into
blocks he's willing to analyze each
block completely de novo completely from
the beginning as if you'd never seen
anything he doesn't remember when he's
looking at block number two what
happened in block number one all right
well how do I aggregate what Feinberg
does so you know he looks at this stuff
he decides he wants to publish various
statistics what do I do how do I
aggregate my fine Birds okay so and then
the game for him and when my ground
rules will they okay Steve you can look
at the data but you must follow these
instructions you have to you know repeat
your activity with a fresh mind on each
block and you have to feed your your
intermediate results into the private
aggregator and never tell the world
anything except what the aggregator says
those are the rules so what's the
motivation for this problem other than
arguing with Feinberg on a public stage
so he wants to do research and he wants
to publish the results of his research
and he's going to write a paper maybe
that will say well you know like he
might say look I'll look at the raw data
and then I'll figure out what statistic
it is I want to publish then I will use
a differentially private algorithm to
publish that statistic is it safe or is
it not safe let's say that again I let
Feinberg look at the data suppose I
don't make him I don't do sample and
aggregate I just let him look at the
data decide what he wants to publish and
then take that statistic and compute it
with a differentially private estimator
and release it is that safe no good why
not
ok
well the paper is going to say using
differentially private robust regression
we find a link between income and health
what the paper won't tell you was I
chose to use a robust regression because
the billionaire Warren Buffett was in
the data set but it may still be true so
the fact that he chose robust regression
is not a differentially private thing he
wouldn't have chosen it perhaps had
Warren Buffett not that in the data set
the chance of choosing with a robust
regression is zero without Buffett
nonzero with Buffett so we have a
violation of differential privacy so
what we want to do is we want to make
the choice of computations private which
thing it is you are going to compute in
a differentially private way to show the
public that choice has to be made
private and we don't know how Feinberg
decides what to do so that's the
motivation for that problem so here's
one solution we can aggregate using the
exponential mechanism so well let's say
there are there's a menu of items of
functions that that Feinberg might
choose to release to the public so on
one block things right here here's the
menu of functions the Hat the chew the
car the dog do you recognize these toys
from the game monopoly ok so so on 15 of
the blocks that says the shoe I'm going
to publish robust regression I know
blocks doesn't say I want to do logistic
regression on three blocks it says I
want to I don't know you make something
up all right and so on so we just you
know take these votes and we apply the
exponential mechanism to determine with
high problem if there's if there's a
strong majority guy that'll be chosen
right so the nice thing is it will
always return a valid outcome and
it's guaranteed to be epsilon zero
differentially private but a little bit
of thinking ends up showing you that you
need a lot of blocks to do this even if
Feinberg always makes the same choice so
here's another solution instead we could
try the proposed test release method we
do everything as we started before but
for aggregation what we do is we test
for a strong majority is there a
potential item a toy so that a strong
majority of the blocks say publish that
statistic and if so we go ahead and we
publish that statistic in a
differentially private way and otherwise
we just say hey you know that Feinberg's
all over the map here this isn't a good
computation and we quit maybe in this
case we would go back and use I don't
know nevermind just we just fail so
that's the Feinberg problem and there's
a lot that you might want to look into
here but it is really interesting to me
that at least theoretically it's not a
hundred percent hopeless from the get-go
theoretically there's an opening for a
solution all right oh yeah here are the
properties of the second solution the
number of blocks that's required is
independent of the number of outcomes
but the bad property is the aggregation
fails if no outcome is a strong majority
okay another fun and games problem
remember this result which says that if
you're going to answer really large
numbers of queries with non-trivial
accuracy then you can't have a
completely distributed solution there
has to be coordination among
the answers that are handed out what
does that tell you about privacy for the
questions themselves the answer I hand
out for question number 26 depends on
what was asked and maybe what I answered
in question number three so if this is a
database that's usable by the public
later people who come in may learn
something about what kinds of diseases
the earlier people were trying to find
out about a potential privacy violation
not for the data the data stay private
now it's privacy for the analyst so the
second interpretation of this theorem is
that there's an analyst privacy problem
and the result that I'll just give you
the shape of a won't go to any proofs is
that there is a stateful algorithm
providing differential privacy for the
analyst I'll go into a little bit more
detail than this slide but the general
idea is this the analysts are neat will
need to have IDs and I'll explain in a
minute how they're used here's the
database it's going to be protected by
let's say private multiplicative weights
which will guarantee some kind of alpha
accuracy okay now in private
multiplicative weights we are hiding
very small changes to the data set let's
say this is counting queries we're
hiding sort of amounts on the order of 1
over N because it's fractional answers
that we're giving or one if it's
flat-out counting queries the errors
this thing makes our most alpha so we're
going to do is we're going to kind of
hide the history of what questions were
asked before by using another version of
private multiplicative weights that hide
the errors that are introduced here
so these will be alpha hiding so alpha
sized deviations are going to be
protected by privacy so what happens
okay so the first analyst comes along it
asks a question it interacts with the
outer layer private multiplicative way
to algorithm that forwards the question
on to the inner layer which forwards you
know consults the database gives an
answer and the answer has noise Annette
to protect the privacy of the data and
then we do a little bit more noise in
some sense to protect the privacy of
small fluctuations in that answer a all
right and we continue this way now the
next analyst comes along and we start up
a new copy of the private multiplicative
waits algorithm this thing is going to
make it impossible for analysts number
two to figure out whether analyst number
one was there or not why because all of
the questions that analyst number one
did will it most affect the answers that
come out of here by it by alpha because
that's the ER that that's accuracy
promises things won't be wronged by more
than alpha and that accuracy guarantees
days there so if we just hide those
alpha changes this guy doesn't see what
that guy did so that's how the algorithm
works this is so lilz motivate animation
as long uh so we don't answer yes
no because we're using private
multiplicative weight so it can answer a
large number of queries it's not
explicitly adding alpha noise remember
that we proved an alpha beta utility
guarantee for private multiplicative
weights even for very large numbers of
queries so if that accuracy guarantee
that tells us that no matter what
questions were asked in the past the
later answers are still accurate to
within alpha and we're obscuring that by
using alpha hiding out here okay so the
main points are the differential privacy
for the database is handled by the inner
private multiplicative weight algorithm
and suppose we change the queries of all
of the analysts but the last 1 by alpha
accuracy the inner guy is still
answering within about 20 you know plus
or minus 2 alpha of truth and so by
essentially a generalization of
differential privacy the outer one will
ensure that the distribution of answer
is to the last guy are similar okay um
open questions so this gave differential
privacy for the analyst is it possible
to have perfect privacy I don't know
what about collusion among the different
adverse er of different adversarial
analysts I don't know um we get a
deterioration from the private
multiplicative weights algorithm because
of our sort of tool to tiered structure
and we're losing that extra alpha
utility
you know Candace got can we do better
and there's been some progress on these
last two questions recently but it's not
resolved this is an open area okay next
problem this was real so there was a
h1n1 swine flu and there was a website
that you could go to and you would
interact with the website a little bit
tell it a little bit about yourself
including some demographic information
and answering simple questions like do
you have a fever higher than this
temperature and I don't know a couple
other small things and then it would
tell you you might be at risk for the
flu and you should see a doctor or you
probably don't have the flow don't worry
about it and the website has the
following question can we store and
share your answers with health officials
and researchers so the website now wants
to keep the data this demographic
information from the individuals they so
that can be very helpful in monitoring
regional health conditions planned slow
response blah blah blah blah blah but it
also says whoops whoa sted here it also
says um I'll tell you in a minute maybe
so how might you use this this is a
famous real-life example of how public
health information was useful this was
Jon Snow's map of cholera cases in
London they didn't know how cholera was
transmitted but people were getting very
very sick and he made a map of where the
cholera cases were and where the wells
were the pumps that people were using
for water and he figured out what was
going on okay so what else does the
website says it says microsoft may also
disclose information if required to do
so by law or good faith belief blah blah
blah blah blah so this was some sort of
boilerplate text that they put in
so they're asking you to give your info
but they're telling you if we decide we
want to we will share this data so the
worry is what we call mission creep now
I've collected a bunch of data about
people and now I'm going to use it for
some entirely different purpose other
than different from the reason for which
it was collected in the first place how
do you feel about that and you don't get
to tell the name later no don't use it
for this do use it for that so it's
called mission creep you know here's the
mission for why we're doing this and now
our mission is expanding and changing so
it's like think of the children now you
have to let your data be used so what's
an approach one approach will be never
store the data so do your processing in
some kind of way where you never have to
store the data have you ever heard of
any algorithms that do that have you
ever heard of streaming algorithms good
so you might try streaming algorithms
well just because they're streaming
algorithms doesn't mean they preserve
privacy in the following sense the
streaming algorithms may store some
samples that were gathered along the way
streaming says we're not going to store
a whole lot of data typically but it
doesn't say I won't just happen to
record Cynthia's data every time she
shows up so you want some kind of
streaming algorithms oh but streaming
algorithms even if their outputs are
differentially private I was worried
about Microsoft who was holding the data
now using it for something else so it's
not just enough that the outputs
preserve privacy I want the internal
state of the algorithm to be
privacy-preserving okay so in order to
make sense out of this we also have to
now define what do we mean by my data I
mean these people are interacting with
the website three times during the month
of februari I felt pretty lousy so I
went and consulted with this thing
it's not a fixed static database anymore
it's changing so what do we mean by my
data so we started this investigation
into what we call pan private algorithm
so these are algorithms that intuitively
are private inside it out that even if
you combined all of the outputs with the
internal state you would completely hide
the pattern of appearances of any
individual their presence their absence
their frequency and so on so the model
is that data arrive in a stream for
example search queries and the data of
different users are interleaved
completely arbitrarily I could ask two
questions that show up next to each
other or they could be interleaved with
somebody else's it's on um the curators
sees each item and updates its internal
state so here's how it looks here's the
data stream so yellow is the data of one
person gray is the data of another
person blue is the data of a third
person and so on or a query posed by the
third person or whatever and all I'm
worrying about now is the names I'm not
even worrying about what they were
actually queering so the algorithm has
some internal stated we seized the first
input and it means the next input it
reads the next input and so on and um
did I tell you it was continuously
producing outputs that's the next topic
right now it's just processing the
stream and it's going to say something
at the end but we want its internal
state together with what it says at the
end to be private that's why in this
little animation no outputs were being
produced yet so informally pan privacy
says that for every possible behavior of
a user in the stream the Joint
Distribution of the final output and the
internal State at any single point in
time so like you get a subpoena and you
come in and you look at the internal
state everything is to be differentially
private how can you possibly
compute anything in this way you can't
take notes what do you do well there's
actually some interesting things that
you can do sufficiently interesting that
it's worth formalizing our requirement
so we have a universe x of items like
usernames and in this notation look
sorry these were from different talks so
now little x is just a username a
database item um two streams are exigent
if if we remove all of the occurrences
of X in both of them we get the same
output okay it's a very intuitive
definition and there's a national
natural notion of corresponding prefixes
in X adjacent strings so X adjacency
says that two streams are capital X
adjacent if there is some individual and
X for which there are exigent okay so
notice that strings of very different
lanes can be adjacent to each other
because we're trying to hide my presence
or absence from the entire stream and I
could have put in one query six queries
or 600 queries we have to hide me no
matter what so we have pan privacy under
one intrusion if let's say the adversary
gets to exactly once examine the
internal state of the algorithm and of
course also say the output so here's
something that you can do we have a
universe x of people we want to know
what fraction of the people have visited
this website all right
sounds really hard you can't take notes
in terms of who showed because if you
took notes then one intrusion would
reveal somebody's name so you can't keep
a list of all the users that have
appeared you can't keep random subsample
of the users that have appeared uh and
even hashing which is a technique that
shows up in a lot of algorithms hashing
is not differentially private you know
my name hashes to this Sun Jeeves name
doesn't hash to this so if if we see
this we can rule him out and he has zero
problem I'm sorry oh well you can make
up an example where this works right my
name hashes to something that's recorded
in some other database I don't show up
and there is no hash of anybody to that
value so a hash value appears here with
some probability here with zero
probability ratio bad okay so we can't
hash Oh does anybody want to guess how
to do it suppose I tell you you can have
lots and lots of internal state if you
want you actually know the tool that
will let you do this okay here's what we
do I'll tell you the very very big state
one there's a smaller state one but that
obscures the point so we'll have a giant
table with one bit for every possible
user I'm going to have to similar
probability distributions let me call
them d0 and d1 d0 is 50-50 01 d 1 is
slightly biased toward one now we
initialize the table by choosing from d0
or it's flipping a coin for every entry
in the table so the table initially is
completely random and now we start
processing the stream every time I
appear we choose from d1 and record the
output if I appear 10 times in the
stream every single time we ignore
what's currently written we choose again
from d1 and record the output so the
database will look exactly the same if I
have appeared 1 2 3 4 1 million 7
million times doesn't matter the
database will appear we almost the same
distribution whether I appear 0 times or
one time why because this is just
randomized response for each bit and you
know you can answer fractional queries
with randomized response you already saw
that so that's how we done so you can
actually do something in this model and
it turns out you can do a few different
things in this model okay um multiple
intrusions are more complicated because
in some sense you would have to refresh
the table each time moreover if you
don't know an intrusion has happened
because somebody hacked into your system
rather than the police coming with a
legal court order saying we get to see
your internal state if then you can't
tell how many times it's happened and
you don't know when you need to refresh
your initial random your internal
randomness so there are there are
theorems about what can happen here
alright um another problem let's go back
to the Jon Snow map this was a static
situation let's say a lot of people had
been
click so he makes the map once and he
analyzes the map okay but we're
interested in the case where we actually
want to follow the spread of a disease
over time or just some other kind of
online monitoring so we have a continual
observation algorithm which is an
algorithm that produces an observable
output at every time step for example
there are certain pages where if you
visit them it tells you you are the
700th person to visit this page right
this is a continual output kind of
situation um citations if you ask Google
Scholar how many times says this paper
been cited it'll tell you ah ok so let's
not worry about pan privacy right now
let's just worry about the outputs so
the output is the algorithm has some
kind of state it processes the first
data item tell me you're going to
produce output it promises the second
one ah decides to produce an output
process is the third one produces an
output and so on ok so now in this model
the adversary like
we're talking about how monitoring a
system over time the adversary knows
what time it is right so if you're
looking at how many citations there are
the adversary can tell the difference
between weather and
you yes it can tell whether it was
sighted on Monday on Tuesday on
Wednesday on Thursday it can tell that
it was not cited for several days in a
row it knows what time it is so we say
we have to have a different notion of
adjacency now that will allow us to
capture time so we say that two things
are exigent if there are two data items
in the set so that one string can be
obtained from the other by of replacing
some number of occurrences of X with X
Prime and we introduce an extra symbol
bottom to indicate nothing happened so
now we can hide my presence at time T by
replacing my access to something with
the symbol bottom and we want to be sure
that the adversary can't tell the
difference so what kinds of things do we
do in this model well first of all
there's a general theorem that allows us
for monotone functions to say if you
have a app and private algorithm for the
monotone function then we can get a pan
private algorithm under continual
observation but a fun one that I'll tell
you a little bit about instead of the
heavy-hitting one is counters we've been
talking about counters informally how
many times was the paper cited so
counters what we want to do here now is
we want to be able to handle event level
privacy so um yeah the way this paper
the way Molina oo rephrase this
originally was money who had been guy
Roth Klum's masters adviser phrase the
problem as does guide do what he is told
Moni tells guy go read this paper and of
mine I mean no of monies and then Moni
checks how many people have come to his
website to download papers guy didn't
download the paper last night
the count didn't change so the question
was does guy do what he's full told and
we want to give guy privacy and this is
a kind of event level privacy we want to
know not whether he ever read any paper
moniz but whether he did what he was
told and read it last night so their
turn although you know this is a kind of
silly motivation there are many
applications of counters that give you
this kind of privacy and the literature
talks about these little bit they
include aggregating expert advice
minimizing regret and counter based user
level pan private algorithms meant level
privacy is a much much weaker guarantee
than user level privacy user-level
privacy says we hide all of the this
user's appearances in the stream event
level privacy says we'll hide a few you
know okay so how do you do the counter
though as I said this is flavors of
results we also have counter distortion
lower bounds under continual intrusion
fine so sorry uh this is what the
picture should be suppose we knew in
advance how long we wanted to run the
counter for you know some number two
units of time let's assume for
simplicity that T is a power of two so
what we're going to do is we're going to
maintain counter counters for all these
sort of natural intervals whose lengths
our powers of two so let me just show
you the pattern it's easier than giving
the formal description so one power of
two is one so there's a counter for each
of these intervals one power of two is
two so there's a counter for each of
these intervals right one is four and so
on so you get the pattern right now
these are counters that initially before
they are completed before their time
interval is completed we keep them
secret and this is not a pan private
algorithm the internal state does have
information in it that can be fixed but
for now let's pan private so we're going
to count how many people have shown up
let's say this counter is showing how
many people showed up in steps that must
be eat so 9 10 11 and 12 something like
that all right when that interval is
finished we add Laplace noise to the
result and we publish that so whenever
an interval is finished a noisy version
of how many events took place in there
is published now suppose that time I I
want to know how many events have taken
place up through time I so what I do is
I find a union of at most log 2 of T
segments disjoint segments that cover
the time interval from 1 through I and
you know how to do this you get this
from the binary representation of I so
we only need to give an answer we only
need log of T segments now how many
segments can any given time I appear in
again at most log of T so we can add
noise that's scaled to log of T over
epsilon and then buy a chair lifestyle
bound for the some of the places we
actually can show oh what did I do wrong
right that's how many segments there are
but I'm adding up log T of them so we're
gonna get a bit more noise than log T
it'll be with high probability at most
log T to the 1.5 over epsilon
all right now this last one and this is
the last one it's a short lecture I want
you to help me solve this problem you
have a number of tools at your disposal
and I want you to try to figure out an
approach to this so the general problem
is traffic reporting in a place where
the traffic isn't quite as bad as it is
here so that sometimes the roads are
emptying and sometimes they're a little
crowded and sometimes they're very
crowded oh and that's what you're
familiar with pictures like this then
the green is showing that you can drive
at the speed limit in here the yellow is
showing that it's a little bit slow and
the red is showing is very congested so
uh how does Google Maps get this data
well they get it from the android phones
they monitor people's android phones and
see i mean i think this is how they do
it and see how fast they're moving and
draw some conclusions from there and
what we'd like to do is guarantee some
kind of privacy for the phone users so
privacy should be easy right there are a
lot of cars your presence or absence
doesn't usually affect traffic very much
so it should be easy why might it be
hard
if you're the only one driving that's
interesting that's a very interesting
suggestion there's something to that
what else
only care about the release data good
question where this is like we're back
to the standard model now what problems
does it remind you of what did we just
talk about are we doing this just once
are we doing this all the time it's a
continual situation what else does it
remind you of let's see why it might be
a hard problem I mean the word continual
should give you an idea of why it might
be hard you drive all the time you
constantly are affecting things a little
bit and moreover there's a lot of public
information to help the attacker like on
the radio they tell you the 101 freeway
is you know slow between here and here
and stuff like that you might even cause
a traffic jam in which case your
presence or absence makes a really big
difference will give an example so we
want to sort of privately report average
speeds on say shoreline boulevard that's
right near our lab right now and this is
easy you know how to privately report
one
the problem here is that we want the
average speeds on all major roads at all
times that's a lot of measurements a
whole lot of measurements and if you
drive much more slowly than a lot of the
people around you that might show up if
you drive a whole lot more quickly than
the other people on the road that might
show up okay so anymore is yet on how to
do this or any problems come to mind any
techniques that you've seen come to mind
well
think about what you know about traffic
during rush hour is the street in
downtown hyderabad likely to be crowded
or not crowded right so they tell it's
crowded so what you knew this already
anyway in the middle of the night street
in downtown hyderabad crowded are not
crowded not crowded the traffic report
says it's not crowded but you knew this
anyways it's the middle of the night no
one's driving of course it's not crowded
it's this thing to sound like something
familiar a whole lot of the time you
already know the answer and it's only
interesting when there's some kind of a
weirdness that happens an anomaly of
some sort what technique what was that
exactly so it's starting to sound like
sparse vector sparse vector seems so far
we don't have like a perfect answer to
this problem yet but it seems so far to
be a better approach than the continual
observation stuff that's it has been
more useful so here we want to say
suppose we could predict the answer to
every query what's the speed what speed
are people going on shoreline boulevard
at 10 at night 35 miles an hour if
there's anybody what about an 11 35
miles an hour midnight 35 miles an hour
right so most of the time when most of
the time really because we know so much
so much information auxiliary
information is out there in the public
domain the whole history of everything
that ever happened is public so a lot of
times we can predict so we could just
proporta predictions and almost all the
time we're gonna be right it's great now
suppose we could just instead predict
the answers to most queries we want to
use the private measurements to correct
for our bad predictions so you expect it
to be 35 miles an hour but it turns out
to be 5 miles an hour so instead of
answering 35 as usual oh gosh I'm sorry
I messed up the slide I messed up the
slide so suppose this for 32 you'd say
it's pretty close to 35 significant the
insignificant so i'll just say 35 which
is what we predicted which is in keeping
with the sparse vector approach but now
instead suppose it's five miles an hour
so 35-5 that's a big difference this is
significant so you want to report
something closer to the truth five or
close to it
okay so sparse vector seems promising in
this setting but of course we're running
predictions and sparse vector all over
the place we still haven't gotten away
from the fact that we're monitoring
traffic all of the place all of the time
so we can't necessarily even use farce
vector everywhere whenever our
prediction is wrong we're going to pay
for a failure that's what significant
meant as opposed to insignificant we
would pay something so did we win have
we gotten anywhere not clear anything
else come to mind this is not an obvious
one sparse vector was fairly obvious
this is this is not obvious but you've
actually seen some technology that helps
you at least think about this problem in
a way that leads to something that could
be considered a solution
it can't be independent at all places
right where did we see something like
that I'm wrong direction one direction
remember the difference between epsilon
zero differential privacy and epsilon
delta epsilon zero said simultaneously
for all pairs 6x simultaneously for all
adjacent X Prime you can't distinguish X
from X prime epsilon delta allowed a
relaxation of that it says fix X and X
Prime with high probability you can't
tell the difference so it's kind of like
that or it's kind of like this thing
that I told you to think about with
advanced composition where for the
databases that I'm actually in you can't
sort of tell that I was in them or not
but it doesn't protect my absence
simultaneously from all of the other
databases that's again the same sort of
epsilon delta ish guarantee this like
not quite the quantifiers that you would
have wanted but still not necessarily
bad so we'll do something analogous in
some sense will say that to traffic
databases which are of course being
updated all the time our neighbors if
they differ only on one users data and
moreover it's absolutely differentially
private for database day and Driver I
and will name the route are if for every
of every event in the range the
probability that we see
this event oh yes when um we have
database d is very close to what happens
on the neighboring database d prime
where the drivers root r is deleted from
the database so this database has the
drivers route this one has it deleted
okay so this should be a very very
familiar feeling to you this should feel
like this is the third time or so that
you're seeing it so what does this
definition protect it'll protect things
like you said you were going to the bank
but in fact you stayed home and took a
nap can't tell the difference um you
stayed home I'm sorry it should be D
Prime in the database d prime where you
drove to the bank the prediction maybe
failed on the way to the bank actually
this will work this statement is true
whether it's D or D Prime it's like mil
maybe we're predicting clear traffic but
if I go that would just take things over
the edge and make it congested so we
want to protect my presence or absence
in that way and this definition assumes
i mean protects the case where the
adversary sort of only gets one
measurement to help it distinguish
between the case where i stayed home or
i went to the bank obviously it'll give
slightly worse protection for the
adverse against the adversary who can
take several measurements and this thing
works fine if we're just trying to
distinguish between whether cynthia
stayed home or went to the bank it's
completely and the adversary doesn't
care that there's some presidential
motorcade somewhere else that's causing
strange traffic jams everywhere so
predictions were failing over there but
on the roots that I might have driven
nothing's happening that's really weird
so everybody's just going with the
predictions here's what it doesn't
protect i am the presidential motorcade
everywhere I go I cause traffic jams and
strange behavior okay so it doesn't
protect whether this traffic demon is
staying still or moving um maybe for
some other reason in the database d the
prediction will fail exactly where I am
where I'm going it won't protect that ah
if the adversary gets a whole lot of
measurements it doesn't protect against
that and I have no idea what can happen
what we can I mean this is like thinking
in process I don't know what we can do
to make things better here you might
wonder where did these predictions come
from and I already hinted at that you
know we want to use we want to rely on
the sparse vector technique so sparse
vector technique requires that the
adversary actually knows most of the
time what to expect in the private
multiplicative weights algorithm or in
the sparse right thumb private
multiplicative weights algorithm the
adversary knows this sort of what were
we calling it the estimate X sub T in
the sparse vector algorithm the
adversary knows the expected value
insignificant only learn something new
when it gets a value of significant so
where do we get the information for this
setting well we want to exploit what's
publicly known so there's a huge amount
of public data there's historical data
there's the accident reports from the
police scanner if we're Microsoft and
we're trying to protect privacy for
people using who are allowing us to
predict traffic using their data we can
say hey the google data is public data
it's published I can use it in my
predictor is kind of a joke but alright
event calendars you know there's unch on
shoreline boulevard at the end of
shoreline there's an outdoor theater
that has big concerts but the schedule
for these concerts is of course publicly
known we know that if there is a concert
schedule that ate the traffic will be
really bad after seven you know that
kind of thing there are traffic cameras
that are you know showing on the web so
there's a lot of stuff that we could
mobilize and they can be combined into
an effective model so you can use them
and you can feed them into a predictor
and get some kind of expected behavior
and only signal changes from that okay
that's the end
you